yes Melissa McCarthy and Bal Falcone end
up in a tracksuit how are you I love
that it's so beautiful tonight
you still look great it's less glamorous
Melissa not to me guys I've doubled my
diamonds I feel great what was tonight
like was it a dream I mean just to be to
be in there to be included in any way to
see all these people I love and admire
and and you get to like hang out with
them it's all like yeah you're floating
in a little cloud who do you think has
more chemistry the two of you been
married many years or Bradley Cooper and
Lady gaga they really do have I mean I
have to say us because he gave me a ring
but they really do they have you know
net use you felt it in the movie they
really and I think they've become really
dear friends you can feel it and it's
lovely when they were singing tonight I
was like oh my god there's like they're
so close it was really beautiful it's
nice to see people when you collaborate
that it works on it works at a deep
level like you know for a Ben and
Melissa level you know what I mean it's
nice though it's like you know when you
when you get to work with somebody and
and you care what for them in it and it
grows like that's like you know working
with Richard II grant on this movie he
was drinking waters right over the tall
drink of water you know it's like that
doesn't always happen you meet people
but like there's certain people you meet
we were just like I'm pretty sure we'll
be friends forever and like it changes
yeah I saw that on your Instagram over
and made our whole family eggs and then
got on my trampoline loved him to death
and he brought his wonderful daughter I
mean it was so great is my Richard
they're like it's my Richard coming I'm
like I don't know I don't really want to
like claim him but whose idea was this I
just thought cuz we were like should we
changed and I was like oh I have an idea
but I will say when I heard that I was
like oh god yes 150 percent yes let's do
this you're my best dress best dress at
the Vanity Fair Oscar party Melissa and
Ben ladies and gentlemen even with a
sneaker
but you know what you do have some big
diamonds and I came around I devil
whatever had on the Oscars I doubled so
now it's like I wouldn't trust me with
it
[Music]